la amazonía brasileña en llamas
estas imágenes marcan el inicio el pico
tradicional de la temporada anual de
incendios en esta región del país las
llamas podrían agravarse debido a la
falta de zonas húmedas en la selva como
consecuencia de la deforestación
lamentablemente los incendios nos
sorprenden la deforestación que vivimos
en julio llegó a 1.487 kilómetros
cuadrados es el mismo nivel que el año
pasado
en lo corrido del año han sido
deforestados más de 5 mil kilómetros
cuadrados de bosque equivalente a un
área siete veces mayor al tamaño de la
ciudad de nueva york pero el gobierno de
jair bolsonaro no toma cartas en el
asunto para frenar la crisis ambiental
para los ambientalistas las políticas de
bolsonaro sólo empeoran la deforestación
hay una política gubernamental
deliberada para reducir la acción de los
órganos gubernamentales de control
ambiental en las áreas ambientales esto
ha sido cubierto por los medios tenemos
números de reducción de presupuesto y de
disminución de acciones en el campo
en julio el ministerio de ambiente de
brasil otorgó un permiso inicial que
permitiría la construcción de una
carretera a través del centro de la
selva tropical a esto se suma la falta
de regulación por parte de las
autoridades a la actividad ganadera uno
de los principales sectores causantes de
la tala de árboles a menos de dos meses
de las elecciones presidenciales el
gobierno de bolsonaro pasa a la historia
como la gestión en la que anualmente más
de 10.000 kilómetros cuadrados de bosque
se deforestaron en la región considerada
como el pulmón del mundo